SEAN HANNITY.
♪ ♪
>> AMERICANS HELD HOSTAGE BEHIND
ENEMY LINES, DAY 27.
>> Sean: DAY 27, AMERICANS
HELD HOSTAGE BEHIND ENEMY LINES.
A LOT OF NEWS TO BRING ON THAT
FRONT TONIGHT, TONIGHT LET'S
START WITH YOUR FREEDOM IS UNDER
ASSAULT EMMA DR. JOE BIDEN.
NOT SURE WHAT MEDICAL SCHOOL HE
WENT TO WON'T TAKE NO FOR AN
ANSWER.
NOW IT'S YOUR BODY, IT'S HIS
CHOICE.
WITH AN UNCONSTITUTIONAL,
ILLEGAL, AND ETHICAL, FEDERAL
VACCINE MANDATED THAT BY THE
WAY, HE SAID HE WOULD NEVER
SUPPORT.
ONE THAT JEN PSAKI TOLD US IS
NOT TO THE ROLE OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO DO, ONE THAT
NANCY PELOSI SAID, THEY DON'T
HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO DO IT.
AND KAMALA HARRIS WAS THE ONE
THAT SAID IT'S YOUR BODY, YOU
GET TO MAKE THE CHOICE.
AND TO MAKE MATTERS WORSE, THIS
HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH YOUR
HEALTH OR SAFETY.
THIS IS A COLD AND CALCULATED,
AND POLITICAL PLOY.
BIDEN'S PRESIDENCY HAS BEEN A
COMPLETE DISASTER IN EVERY
SINGLE WAY.
THINK OF ONE THING, CAN YOU NAME
ONE THING THAT HE HAS DONE THAT
YOU CAN POINT TO THAT YOU THINK
IS A SUCCESS?
THE ABANDONED AMERICANS BEHIND
ENEMY LINES CAN'T EVEN TELL US
HOW MANY.
13 AMERICAN HEROES ARE NOW DEAD
BECAUSE OF JOE'S AFGHAN
DISASTER.
WHEN HE HAD CONTROL OF KABUL AND
COULD'VE GOTTEN EVERY AMERICAN
OUT SAFELY, EVERY AFGHAN ALLY
OUT SAFELY.
HIS POLL NUMBERS ARE IN THE
BASEMENT.
HE IS DESPERATE TO GALVANIZE
SUPPORT AROUND A SHARED FILLING
A COMMON ENEMY.
THAT ENEMY AS OF AMERICANS THAT
DON'T BUY INTO HIS
ONE-SIZE-FITS-ALL UNSCIENTIFIC
MEDICINE.
THINK ABOUT THIS.
ONE-SIZE-FITS-ALL, NO MEDICAL
EXEMPTION?
LET'S START THERE.
HOW IS THAT FOLLOWING SCIENCE?
IT'S NOT.
ESPECIALLY THOSE THAT REFUSE TO
FOLLOW THE VACCINE RULES AND
MANDATES INCLUDING REPUBLICAN
GOVERNORS, BY THE WAY WHO WON'T
ACT LIKE MANY DICTATORS WHO
ACTUALLY BELIEVE STRONGLY IN A
PRINCIPLED ATTITUDE JOE GIVES
LIP SERVICE TO AND IT'S CALLED
LIBERTY AND FREEDOM.
AND CHOICE.
JOE SAYS IT'S NOT ABOUT FREEDOM
OR CHOICE, IT IS ABOUT FREEDOM.
IT IS ABOUT YOUR CHOICE.
IT IS ABOUT YOUR UNIQUE MEDICAL
HISTORY AND YOUR CURRENT MEDICAL
CONDITION.
AND WHAT YOUR DOCTOR THINKS, NOT
A PHONY DOCTOR OR A TV GUY THAT
THINKS THEY ARE A DOCTOR OR
PLAYS A DOCTOR ON TV.
AMERICANS HAVE VALUED THEIR
MEDICAL PRIVACY.
AMERICANS HAVE VALUED
DOCTOR/PATIENT CONFIDENTIALITY.
AND ANYONE ELSE WHO BELIEVES IN
PERSONAL FREEDOM, JOE BIDEN'S
HEARTFELT UNITY PLEDGE, OH, THAT
LASTED ALL BUT SEVEN MONTHS.
NOW IT'S US VERSUS THEM.
AND DR. JOE'S PATIENCE IS
WEARING THIN.
HE WANTS TO LECTURE YOU IN
SCHOOL TO YOU FOR NOT LISTENING.
>> RESTORING THE SOUL AND FUTURE
OF AMERICA REQUIRES SO MUCH MORE
THAN WORDS.
IT REQUIRES THE MOST ELUSIVE OF
ALL THINGS IN A DEMOCRACY,
UNITY.
>> THIS IS NOT ABOUT FREEDOM OR
PERSONAL CHOICE, IT'S ABOUT
PROTECTING YOURSELF --
>> MY WHOLE SOUL IS IN THIS.
BRINGING AMERICANS TOGETHER,
UNITING OUR PEOPLE.
MY MESSAGE TO UNVACCINATED
AMERICANS IS THIS, WHAT MORE IS
THERE TO WAIT FOR?
WHAT MORE DO YOU NEED TO SEE?
WITH UNITY, WE CAN DO GREAT
THINGS, IMPORTANT THINGS.
WE'VE BEEN PATIENT, BUT OUR
PATIENCE IS WEARING THIN.
THIS IS OUR HISTORIC MOMENT OF
CRISIS AND CHALLENGE, AND UNITY
IS THE PATH FORWARD.
AND YOUR REFUSAL HAS COST ALL OF
US.
SO PLEASE DO THE RIGHT THING.
>> Sean: NOW CLEARLY JOE'S
UNITY PLEDGE WAS ALIVE.
HALF THE COUNTRY IS ENEMY NUMBER
ONE?
THEY DON'T WANT TO FOLLOW
DR. JOE?
IN FACT, DEMOCRATS SAY NICER
THINGS ABOUT THE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS AND EVEN THOUGH
TALIBAN SOME OF THEM THEN THE
80 MILLION UNVACCINATED
AMERICANS, I GUESS IT'S OPEN
SEASON ON THEM.
DO YOU KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT THEIR
MEDICAL CONDITION?
MEDICAL HISTORY?
ANYTHING ABOUT WHETHER DOCTORS
ARE ADVISING THEM?
ACCORDING TO THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION, 20 YEARS AFTER
9/11, THE TALIBAN'S PROFESSIONAL
AND THEY ARE BUSINESS-LIKE.
IF YOU ARE UNVACCINATED ANYWHERE
IN AMERICAN UNVACCINATED, YOU
ARE IGNORANT.
YOU ARE SELFISH.
HIS PATIENCE IS RUNNING OUT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> TIME TO START PRIORITIZING
ICU BEDS FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE
VACCINATED.
>> THE TALIBAN IS BUSINESSLIKE
AND PROFESSIONAL, THEY HAVE AN
FBI WANTED POSTER, A $10 MILLION
BOUNTY ON HIM.
>> IN ORDER TO GET THOSE PEOPLE
OUT WE HAVE TO WORK WITH SOME OF
THE MEMBERS OF TALIBAN TO PRESS
THEM AND TO WORK IN A
BUSINESS-LIKE MANNER TO GET THEM
OUT.
>> I THINK IF YOU DON'T WANT TO
PLAY BY ANY OF THOSE RULES AND
YOU END UP IN THE HOSPITAL, I
FEEL BAD, BUT MAYBE YOU SHOULD
NOT GO AND TAKE UP THE RESOURCES
FROM SOMEONE ELSE?
>> IMMIGRANTS COMING TO OUR
COUNTRY AND NEWCOMERS WITH HOPES
AND DREAMS AND ASPIRATIONS, WITH
THEIR OPTIMISM AND DETERMINATION
TO MAKE THE FUTURE BETTER FOR
THEIR FAMILIES, WELL, THOSE ARE
AMERICAN TRAITS.
>> Sean: ACCORDING TO THE LEFT
CROSSING THE BORDERS ILLEGALLY,
BREAKING OUR LAWS, THAT'S
HEROIC.
NO VACCINE MANDATES FOR ILLEGAL
ALIENS OR MANDATORY TESTS, JUST
THE OVERCROWDED CAGES IN THE
MIDDLE OF A PANDEMIC WITH A VERY
HIGH RATE OF COVID POSITIVITY,
INCLUDING THOSE NOT TESTED.
IN THEM, BY THE WAY, YOU GET TO
PICK THE STATE OF YOUR CHOICE,
DISPERSED ALL OVER THE COUNTRY
NOT EVEN GETTING A COVID TEST.
JOE IS FOLLOWING THE SCIENCE?
REALLY?
AND YOU WANT TO LECTURE
AMERICANS AND SCHOOLED AMERICANS
AND TELL THEM HOW BAD THEY ARE
AND HOW THEY SHOULD BE HATED AND
GAVE LICENSE TO ATTACKS ON
PEOPLE THAT HAVE DIFFERENT VIEWS
OR MEDICAL CONDITIONS YOU MIGHT
NOT EVEN KNOW ABOUT.
BUT YOU BETTER GET THE VACCINE
OR DR. JOE BIDEN IS GOING TO
UNLEASH THE FULL FORCE OF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AGAINST YOU.
AND YOUR LOVED ONES AND YOUR
EMPLOYER.
AND YOU WILL BE CANCELED IN
SOCIETY ALTOGETHER.
YOU WILL BE SHUT OUT OF
EVERYTHING.
ILLEGAL ALIENS, BY THE WAY, I
SEE THAT TO ME ORCA'S MOAN TO
USE THAT TERM STARTING TODAY OR
YESTERDAY, THEY GET NO MANDATES
AND FREE TRIPS TO THE STATE,
RIGHT?
FREE TRIPS, NO MANDATES, THEY
GET TO GO TO THE STATE OF YOUR
CHOICE AND FREE HEALTH CARE AND
EDUCATION, YOU PAY FOR THAT ALL
WALL TOTALLY EXEMPT FROM THE
MANDATE.
>> IT'S A REQUIREMENT FOR PEOPLE
AT A BUSINESS WITH MORE THAN 100
PEOPLE, BUT IT IS NOT A
REQUIREMENT FOR MIGRANTS?
WHY?
>> THAT'S CORRECT, GO AHEAD.
>> Sean: THE RULES DON'T APPLY
TO ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS, ARE
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS OR THEIR
STAFFERS, IT WAS NOT EVEN TO ALL
POSTAL WORKERS UNTIL PRESSURE
FORCE THE ADMINISTRATION TO
REVERSE COURSE LATE TODAY, BUT
IT DOES APPLY TO LAW-ABIDING
AMERICANS.
IT DOES NOT MATTER IF YOU HAVE A
PRE-EXISTING CONDITION, AND YOU
THINK -- YOUR DOCTOR THINKS
TAKING THE VACCINE IS RISKY AND
NOT THE RIGHT HOST FOR YOU.
IT DOES NOT MATTER IF YOU HAD
COVID OR T-CELL IMMUNITY FROM A
PRIOR INFECTION.
CLEVELAND CLINIC SAYS THAT
SCIENCE IS PRETTY CLEAR ON THAT
SO FAR, IT DOES NOT MATTER IF
YOU PREFER TO KEEP YOUR MEDICAL
DECISIONS PRIVATE.
THE FRAIL, THE WEEK, THE
MENTALLY INCOMPETENT,
IMPAIRED-PRESIDENT, DR. JOE
KNOWS BEST.
AND OF COURSE THE MANDATE IS
DEEPLY UNCONSTITUTIONAL AMONG
ALL OF THIS.
AT LEAST TEN GOVERNORS ARE
PLANNING LEGAL ACTION INCLUDING
GOVERNOR ABBOTT,
GOVERNOR DeSANTIS, AND SHADOW
PRESIDENT CHIEF OF STAFF RON
CLAIM IS CONGRATULATING HIMSELF
PULLING THE NEW MANDATE TO THE
ULTIMATE WORK AROUND FOR A
VACCINE REQUIREMENT.
BUT ANYONE WITH A FUNCTIONING
BRAIN KNOWS THAT THE MANDATE IS
IN SERIOUS LEGAL JEOPARDY, EVEN
FAKE NEW CNN ATTORNEYS RECOGNIZE
THIS.
AND THAT'S WHY A FEW MONTHS AGO
SEVERAL TOP DEMOCRATS PROMISED
THEY WOULD BE NO FEDERAL VACCINE
MANDATE, BECAUSE IT IS NOT THE
ROLE OF THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
TAKE A LOOK HOW THINGS CHANGE.
>> WILL IT BE MANDATORY?
>> NO, I WOULD NOT DEMAND IT BE
MANDATORY.
>> PERHAPS FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
SHOULD STEP IN, AND UNVACCINATED
PEOPLE AHEAD OF THE NEEDS OF
VACCINATED PEOPLE?
>> THE QUESTION, THAT IS NOT THE
ROLE OF THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
THAT IS THE ROLE THAT
INSTITUTIONS, PRIVATE SECTOR
ENTITIES, AND OTHERS MAY TAKE.
>> WE CANNOT REQUIRE SOMEONE TO
BE VACCINATED, THAT'S JUST NOT
WHAT WE CAN DO.
>> I AM ALL FOR A MORE
VACCINATION, BUT IT'S COMING YOU
KNOW, I HAVE NOTHING FURTHER TO
SAY ON THAT EXCEPT THAT WE ARE
LOOKING INTO THE POLICIES.
AND QUITE HONESTLY, IF PEOPLE DO
THAT LOCALLY, THOSE ARE
INDIVIDUAL LOCAL DECISIONS AS
WELL.
>> I DON'T THINK YOU WILL SEE A
MANDATE A VACCINE FOR THE
GENERAL PUBLIC.
>> Sean: OH, OKAY.
ANOTHER BIG CHANGE, GOALPOSTS
MOVE EVERY DAY.
WHY WOULD ANYONE HAVE ANY FAITH?
YOU WANT TO KNOW WHERE THE
VACCINE HESITANCY COMES FROM?
THE PEOPLE THAT CHANGED HER MIND
EVERY FIVE SECONDS AND THE
PEOPLE THAT WERE WRONG IN EVERY
PREDICTION THEY EVER MADE.
THEY KEEP CHANGING EVERYTHING
EVERYTHING THE DAY.
NO MASK, ONE MASK, TWO MASS, NOW
TEN MASKS, BACKS, MASK, ADD A
BOOSTER.
NOW A DESPERATE ATTEMPT AT THE
POLITICAL SCAPEGOAT AND
UNVACCINATED AMERICANS FIT THE
BILL.
THE SAME THAT LEFT OPEN BORDERS
AND NO TESTING OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS WITH A HIGH RATE OF
COVID POSITIVITY AND THEN DUMPED
IN CAGES.
THAT'S RIGHT, A PETRI DISH IF
YOU WILL.
AND DR. JOE JUST CAN'T
UNDERSTAND WHY ANYONE WOULD BE
VACCINE-HESITANT.
WHY ON EARTH WOULD ANYONE NOT
TRUST THE EXPERTS?
THE ONES THAT WERE WRONG ABOUT
THE ORIGINS OF COVID, AND SOME
ACTUALLY REALLY LIED, WE NOW
KNOW, THE TRANSMISSIBILITY OF
COVID, THE USE OF VENTILATORS,
THE VACCINE TIMELINE, THE
THRESHOLD FOR HERD IMMUNITY, THE
ONES WHO PROMISED TWO WEEKS TO
SLOW THE SPREAD.
THE ONES WHO TOLD US NOT TO WEAR
MASKS, THEN ONE, THEN TWO, THEN
OUTDOORS, THEN NO MASKS
OUTDOORS.
AND NOW BOOSTER DO.
AND ON AND ON, CAN YOU KEEP UP?
EVEN JOE AND KAMALA EXPRESSED
HESITANCY OVER THE VACCINE,
MAYBE THEY FORGOT.
>> TO SAY THERE IS A VACCINE
THAT IS APPROVED, AND EVEN
DISTRIBUTED, WOULD YOU GET IT?
>> WELL, I THINK THAT'S GOING TO
BE AN ISSUE FOR ALL OF US, I
WILL SAY THAT I WOULD NOT TRUST
DONALD TRUMP.
>> GETTING VACCINATED IS THE
SINGLE BEST PROTECTION AGAINST
COVID-19, AND ITS VARIANTS.
IT'S THE SINGLE BEST DEFENSE.
>> I TRUST THE SCIENTISTS, BUT I
DON'T TRUST DONALD TRUMP.
AND AT THIS MOMENT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE CAN'T EITHER.
>> I'M GOING TO CONTINUE
EVERYTHING I CAN TO ENCOURAGE
THE UNVACCINATED TO GET
VACCINATED.
THAT INCLUDES ADDRESSING
HESITANCY AND MISINFORMATION HAD
ON.
>> Sean: ACTUALLY, UNLIKE JOE
AND KAMALA, I ACTUALLY BELIEVE
IN THE SCIENCE AND THE SCIENCE
OF VACCINATION UNDER TRUMP AND I
BELIEVE IN THEM NOW.
AS I SAID MANY TIMES, I'M NOT A
DOCTOR.
I CAN'T TELL YOU WHAT TO DO.
I DON'T KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT YOUR
MEDICAL HISTORY OR ANYTHING
ABOUT THE CURRENT MEDICAL
CONDITION.
BUT YOU BETTER TAKE THIS
SERIOUSLY, PEOPLE DIE.
I KNOW PEOPLE THAT HAVE ENDED UP
ON VENTILATORS, SOME THAT BARELY
SURVIVED AND SOME THAT DIED.
I AM A RADIO AND TELEVISION
HOST.
THAT'S RIGHT, I'M A MEMBER OF
THE MOB AND THE MEDIA, BUT THE
GOOD SIDE.
HE HAD TO WE ALSO ARE MEMBERS OF
THE PROCESS.
I'M NOT A MEDICAL DOCTOR.
I DID NOT GO TO MEDICAL SCHOOL.
WE WILL DO OUR BEST TO KEEP YOU
INFORMED AND BRING MEDICAL
EXPERTS WITH ALL DIFFERENT TYPES
OF POINT OF VIEW.
BUT ONLY YOU KNOW THE
CONSULTATION OF YOUR DOCTOR
SHOULD MAKE THAT INFORMED
IMPORTANT DECISION ABOUT A
VACCINE.
NOT ANY TELEVISION HOST OR
FRANKLY ANY SWAMP MEMBER IN D.C.
NOT ANY OF THE ONE TO BE DOCTORS
ON FAKE NEW CNN OR DNC,
CERTAINLY NOT DR. JOE BIDEN.
I WONDER WHAT MEDICAL SCHOOL HE
WENT TO, OR ANYONE IN THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WITHOUT A
MEDICAL LICENSE.
YOU HAVE A PERSONAL
RESPONSIBILITY TO PROTECT
YOURSELF, YOUR FAMILY, AND
OTHERS.
AND HOW YOU DO THAT IS YOUR
BUSINESS, NOT MINE.
BUT YOU DO HAVE THAT
RESPONSIBILITY.
NOT DR. JOE'S EITHER.